c'est la chasse aux enseignants
dans une opération grande
séduction. Et ça marche très
bien.
C'est le tapis rouge déroulé
pour les enseignants.
Mélanie Ladouceur,fraîchement sé
de maternité, sélectionne
les écoles qui l'intéressent.
MÉLANIE LADOUCEUR,
aspirante enseignante
- J'attends en ligne, en fait,
pour parler à une direction.
Donc, on voit les noms
des écoles qui sont inscrites
au mur.
- Au Centre de services scolaire
Marie-Victorin sur la rive sud,
on a pris le taureau
par les cornes pour lutter
contre la pénurie de personnel.
C'est l'opération grand V :
embaucher à grande vitesse
en une seule journée.
Du "speed dating",
selon l'expression populaire.
Plus de 500 personnes
rencontrent des directeurs
et directrices d'écoles.
Ces aspirants profs écrivent
par la suite leurs préférences
d'école sur un formulaire.
SYLVIE CÔTÉ, dir. des RH, Centre
de services scol. Marie-Victorin
- Le Service des ressources
humaines rassemble
tous ces formulaires-là
et essaie de faire ce qu'on
appelle des matchs parfaits
entre les candidats et
les directions d'établissement
qui ont des affectations
à pourvoir.
- Bonjour!
- Vous allez bien?
- Bien, vous?
- Marie-France Labelle,
directrice de l'école
Saint-RoSaint-RoSaint-RoSaint-Ré
comme enseignante.
MARIE-FRANCE LABELLE, dir.,
École primaire Saint-Romain
- Je les trouve très chanceux,
les candidats. Parce que, moi,
je me souviens que je devais
à l'arraché essayer
de me trouver un trois,
quatre jours semaine.
- La hausse substasse substassee
des salaires des enseignants
accordée par le ministre
Roberge, mais aussi les missions
de recrutement à l'étranger
on mandat portent fruit.
Anais Ascione s'est ainsi fait
embaucher directement en France.
Reste à choisir son école.
ANAIS ASCIONE,
aspirante enseigna
- Là, je cherche l'école
Saint-Joseph pour un poste...
en fait, un poste en maternelle
cinq ans.
- Sur 400 postes à combler,
la journée permettra l'embauche
d'environ 350 enseignants, à
temps plein et à temps partiel.
Mais si  bat
son plein ici, toutes les écoles
n'ont pas cette chance.
JOSÉE SCALABRINI, prés., Féd.
des syndicats de l'enseignement
pas représentatif.
On voit, dans différents
milieux, on est en grande
recherche d'enseignants encore.
aine dernière,
dans une tournée médiatique
annoncée aux médias la veillesee
de l'Éducation affirmait
de façon rassurante que
700 postes d'enseignants
restaient à combler.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS ROBERGE,
ministre de l'Éducation, Québec
- Les postes qui sont encore
ouverts, moi, j'ai confiance
qu'on va les combler
avant la rentrée scolaire.
- Jean-François Roberge
soutient que chaque classe
aura un enseignant.
Un adulte, oui, disent
les syndicats. Qualifiés?
Pas nécessairement.
Et ce sera parfois
plusieurs remplaçants.ÉRIC GING,
Centrale des syndicats du Québec
- On sait très bien que,
dans les milieux, il y aura pas
un enfant en péril à la rentrée,
là. Tout le monde va s'en
occuper. Il y aura du monde
qui va être là.
Mais à quel coût? À quel prix?
- Les syndicats affirment
depuis une semaine
inistre de l'Éducation
minimise le problème.
Des vérifications effectuées
par Radio-Canada démontrent
un cafouillage dansmission des .
La veille de la sortie
médiatique du ministre,
Radio-Canada s'est par exemple
vu refuser une demandesur le nos
à combler, sous prétexte
que les données n'étaient pas
disponibles. Le ministère
nous a ensuite fourni le chiffre
de 700 postes vacants,
puis de 924, pour revenir à 700.
Les regroupements
des directions d'école,
eux, sont catégoriques :
il faut doubler ce nombre.
NICOLAS PRÉVOST, prés., Féd.
québ. des établ. d'enseignement
- Nous, on est allésavec un chi,
parce qu'on n'avait pas toutes
les réponses de l'ensemble
des centres de services,
mais on était capamême
d'établir une certaine tendance
et une moyenne. Donc,
on arrivait vers un chiffre
conservateur de 700 autres
postes, pour un total de 1400.
- À ce total, il faut ajouter
des centaines d'autres postes
à combler, notamm
les éducatrices en services
de garde et les techniciennes
en éducation spécialisée
à la veille de la rentrée
scolaire
Ici Julie Marceau,
Radio-Canada, Mon